former president Donald Trump could be
just days away from charges related to
alleged hush money payments to an adult
film star meanwhile the former president
took his first trip to Iowa since
announcing his 2024 presidential run and
as Robert Costa reports he took aim at
his potential rivals
it's great to be in Davenport former
president Trump returned Monday to Iowa
marking his first visit to the early
voting State since he announced his 2024
presidential campaign and every promise
I made to Iowa as a candidate I
fulfilled as your president the stop
came days after Trump Rivals were in
Iowa staking out their own ground we
will fight the woke in the legislature
we will fight the woke in education we
will never ever surrender and on Monday
Trump wasted no time going after Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis now Rhonda Sanctus
strongly opposed ethanol do you know
that and
we don't even know if he's running but
Trump's legal challenges loomed as did a
possible New York indictment he needs to
be held accountable for his Dirty Deeds
Trump's former lawyer Michael Cohen
testified for three hours Monday before
a grand jury in Manhattan Cohen has long
said he made hush money payments to an
adult film star Stormy Daniels on
Trump's behalf during the 2016 campaign
the grand jury has also heard from
former Trump aides hope Hicks and
kellyanne Conway after Trump was asked
to testify last week an attorney for the
former president said he won't be
participating in that proceeding adding
the investigation is with absolutely no
legal Merit this is not going to be a
long drawn-out process former prosecutor
Nick Ackerman says the Manhattan
district attorney likely already has an
indictment for Trump drafted based on
the decision to bring in Cohen the DA's
office knows what they're charging so I
would expect in a matter of days we're
going to see an indictment Trump also
responded yesterday to former vice
president Mike Pence saying history will
hold Trump accountable for the January 6
attack Trump falsely claimed Pence was
responsible for what unfolded that day
since Pence refused to block the
certification of President Biden's
election Nate
Bob thank you